Hey guys, how is it going?
Happy Superbowl-Sunday!
I can't believe it's Superbowl again.
And as you can tell, I'm wearing a Steelers Jersey...
...with my name on it.
I am Steelers fan...
and you know what that means?
That means I don't really care, very much about the Superbowl this year.
But what I do care about is Superbowl-snacks.
Is this, I think like my, my lens is a little dirty of the last video I made.
I forget what I made last.
But I ended up spraying oil, all over my camera?
Who knows? I'm a slob. Should i clean you too?
So today, we're gonna be making some cupcakes...
...I've had this in my pantry for quite a while.
It's Reese's Peanut Butter and Chocolate cupcakes.
There's basicly Peanut Butter filled cupcakes and...
...I really just needed some sort of Football excuse to make them.
So I'm gonna make some kind of like football-themed...
...cake, I don't know what's gonna happen.
I have no idea, all I know is I'm making these and I'm gonna make them edable.
So we're going to need this box.
*Mumbles*
Ya well... okay
If you're just joining me for the first time ever
Welcome! I'm Justine
I try to make everything in a blender
I think it's time I get a new Vitamix
I think I should treat yourself
If you've never made a cake
or anything in a blender before, the first thing
that you wanna do is basically put all of the
wet ingredients in first
2 eggs, 1/3 vegetable...
...this is canola oil
the same thing as vegetable oil?
says it's good for your heart
2/3
ooooooo
NOOOOOOO
It was 1/3!
2/3 cup water...
Shooot...
It's...
right in front of my face...
Right in front of my face
2/3 cups of water!
1/3 cup...
...cool... Things are
really heatin' up now
Speaking of heating up...
Preheat! Baby.
Let's see what's in here...
Cupcake mix, says so right there
Time to blend this up
Nice and tight, get it right!
(wow)
Yaaaass... I bought a bunch
of new spatulas so I'm pretty excited about using them
This one looks like its got a spatula inside of a spatula
It kind of looks like a fish... Let me tell you what
You guys can find a lot of really cool baking
things at the craft store
Okay well those look like they're ready.
Got our baking cups to make things easy
I'm not sure, how much do you put in these?
I feel like every time I do anything I mess
it up
about 2/3 full...
2/3 full?...
Guess that's the problem with a blender...
...I've got half a cupcake stuck in here... Oops
Alright well...
We're gonna be one short...
You look like you might need a little more...
So I guess it's time to put these in the oven
21-26 minutes.
Hey Google! Set a timer for
21 minutes.
(Google) - Alright 21 minutes, starting now
Cool
Alright well I'm gonna clean up my mess and then
we're going to start making the...
peanut butter filling
OH! That's gonna be delicious!
Alright, we're back. Uh... I sorta cleaned up
There's stuff everywhere but that's how we do (Stupidly waves knife)
We need 2 tbsp of butter softened
Not melted!
That's not soft...
That sounds... not good!
That's boiling!
That butter is boiling.
Gosh. Look! I, uh, did some upgrading.
Oh,
wow did you see that incredible pour?
1 tsp
(inhale) 2, 3,
We're going to use this incredible hand mixer
Wonder how those cupcakes are doin'?
Like - Perfection
wow
Here's our... Filling mix. Just
open that up
Oh that smells
absolutely incredible
woah
Woah! Woah! Woah!
That just got absolutely everywhere!
This thing's a piece of crap
I need to get a
better one. Leave me some comments and suggestions on what
hand mixer to get because this thing sucks
These look so good. Oh my gosh! I'm so excited
about this. Reece's
are like my favourite thing ever.
Mmm, Reece cups but em in the
freezer, frozen. Taste so good...
Filling in a pastry bag place bag in
tall glass and fill in bag with... okay
This glass is not very tall but
it's the tallest glass that I can find
In you go!
Well this looks like I have poop in a cup.
Hm.
Well we're back and
the cupcakes are here before me
just, magically and they're actually still very very warm,
so I'm not sure if I should
just fill them now or...
...I don't know...
I think I'm just gonna fill them
We've got our...
...This...
...so gross
I don't know how far to stick it
I don't know if anything's gonna happen, but...
I mean I think something happened.
Oh ya!
It's going in!
Looks like they're all full!
So I guess I'll just kinda
do one at a time
Up here maybe... Alright so
our first one...
Oh! This looks so good!
Okay well, uh, it's a...
It's not like the best thing I've ever iced
but it's definitely not the worst
That seems to be a common theme.
Not the best, but not the worst
Look at these magically iced cupcakes!
I'm incredibly impressed at how
well I did
If I do say so myself, but
these look pretty good! So let's
start decorating. I mean that's really what we're here for
right?
Ya that looks...
mediocre
But you get it...
Oh that looks
just beautiful!
Um, that's  for Super-Bowl 51
MmHm...
You get the point
That one's so much better than that one!
This is grass
that I'm putting on this one
If you can't tell
I'm gonna use this whole thing. This
entire container of green
on this one cupcake. So now I should
probably put some stripes down it
cause it's gonna be like, the
various yard lines
Uh...
I love what we've got going on here
Next... Oops, there's
a flag on the field. What happened?
is there a penalty?
Is there a penalty!?
This is
a flag on the field!
I'm like, running out of things to do
So, uh...
Loving what I've done
with the place
Oh. that's a little bit. The field's a
got a little muddy. Somebody fell in the mud
it started raining. So this one didn't
really turn out very well but, I'm gonna, I'm gonna try
to salvage it
Look at this! It's grass...
Oh God, no. This looks stupid.
This looks so dumb! This looks
so stupid!
This is really not working very well I think
I should just maybe stop decorating
or no one's gonna wanna eat my creations
This is awful...
Well since I'm just about done I guess this is a great time to
ask you guys, who do you want to win the Super-Bowl.
Patriots or Falcons?.
Actually no. I'm going for the Falcons
We've got one last cupcake here and I decided to save this one
because this is a very very very special cupcake
This one, is for
Tom Brady and we're gonna call this, the "Deflate cake"
Here Tom, this one's for you
BABY!
Good luck at the Super-Bowl!
Don't let Tom near your balls!
*Laughs*
Well, thanks for watching.
I'm not
too static about my results but I'm also
not too upset
I might have to do a little bit of explaining to
my guests. I'll be posting a Super-Bowl vlog so
you'll get to see, uh, what everybody thinks of them,
so,
see ya later.
Happy Super-Bowl.
Now I gotta clean up... A lot of mess
So this is uh, behind the scenes
of a cooking video
We've got mess, mess, mess, mess
camera, camera,
monitors so i can see what's going on
and just more mess...
Just a lot, a lot of mess
We've
got batteries, charging non-stop
ya, this is it.
Why?! Wh-
I am so irresponsible
and before you guys
criticized me, ya I'm gonna
say all the terrible things about myself
I'm a idiot, I'm careless, I'm reckless.
Accidents happen - Subscribe to Tyra Mackinnon!